my name is Eric Hipple I'm a venture
capitalists my firm is called Larry
hippo ventures well it's me plus three
other partners we are technology
investors so we look for companies that
use technology primarily consumer
technology doesn't mean that they have
to be consumer facing but the technology
has to be based on the same technology
that we all used day-to-day and so we're
looking for companies that use
technology to either create large new
marketplaces or large new businesses or
who disrupt large businesses that are
already in place and New York is
particularly well suited for this
because there's a lot of people with
very diverse backgrounds diverse domain
knowledge we have a lot of people in the
in our educational system a million kids
in our public school system 600,000 car
students and technology today is
primarily developed in large urban
centers so obviously in New York is
well-positioned for that the difference
between New York and Silicon Valley is
in the kind of technology that people
that we develop here as opposed to in
Silicon Valley first I think we should
point out where the similarities are and
the similarities are that because
technology today is transportable and
rentable and relatively cheap to to use
we in New York but it could be anywhere
it could be Bombay could be Austin have
access to the same technology to develop
new applications new services then
anybody in Silicon Valley so everyone
starts with the same level playing field
the technology is accessible through the
cloud it's rentable through the cloud
anybody can start a company with you
know a couple of laptops and two or
three people and you have in a few
thousand dollars literally and you can
start a company and you can start a
business so it's very different today
than it was just a few years ago where a
large part of the money that you raised
actually went to the equity
the technology you had to buy servers
and yet by hardware you had to buy
expensive software licenses and today
you don't have to do any of that so
that's a big difference but we we have
in New York as as anywhere else access
to the same latest developments in
technology than anybody in Silicon
Valley the the big difference is that
New York focuses more on the software
layer on the application and the
services layer so that we're really good
at software in New York wewe we're good
at at platforms we're good at consumer
facing application we're good at
enterprise software software
as-a-service we're good at a variety of
different domains obviously the ones
that you can think of the traditional
sectors such as advertising and media
and but also healthcare and you know a
variety of different domains where you
have people who have experience and
expertise because they you know some big
companies are located here and big
sectors of the economy are based here
what New York is probably not going to
do is develop the next plumbing for the
internet that's more likely to be coming
out of the West Coast but having said
that we're increasingly getting more
more advanced engineering talent
in New York in fact on Roosevelt Island
there's going to be a Cornell University
and in conjunction with the big
technology Institute in them in Israel
are building a campus and which will be
ready in two or three years but the
classes have already started in other
locations and this is all going to be
advanced applied engineering so who
knows what's going to develop in the
future some hardware is already being
developed in New York we invest invested
for instance in MakerBot the 3d printer
company that was sold recently to
another 3d printer company so so there
is there is a background in in
hardware and manufacturing in New York
but generally speaking it's really
software that that's the the big thing
as it were here in the Oregon